pala stands for a large iron Collider
experiment at the Large Hadron Collider
at CERN in Geneva Switzerland my name is
John Harris I'm a physicist I'm a
professor of physics here at Yale I'm
the national coordinator here in the US
for the Alice experiment the goal of the
Large Hadron Collider with heavy ions
and namely the Alice experiment in
particular is to recreate conditions
that existed some 10 microseconds after
the Big Bang when all of the matter in
the universe was in the form of very hot
soup of quarks and gluons quarks and
gluons are part of the fundamental
constituents that matter there are
different types of quarks that make up
what we see as particles and gluons hold
the quarks together which are the
constituents of the particles that we
know we'd like to study this at such
early times to try and understand how
the universe evolved and we basically
understand what happened since that time
some 10 microseconds after the Big Bang
when later on nuclei and atoms and and
galaxies and solar systems were formed
but as we go backwards towards the Big
Bang and time it is much more difficult
to know and so we're trying to establish
what were the conditions and what really
took place in those first few
microseconds why are we colliding heavy
ions together well heavy ions are heavy
nuclei and we're colliding specifically
led at very very near the speed of light
so they're traveling very fast with
tremendous amount of energy and so all
this energy that they're taking with
them when they collide is being
converted into making particles and
antiparticles so there's matter and
antimatter being made out of energy and
so we have lots of particles coming out
and once we study those particles we
kind of reconstruct back in time back to
when the collision took place and try to
get the temperature
and the properties of the matter that
exists at that very initial part of the
collision the Large Hadron Collider
start operating just this year for
physics and at the very highest energies
ever started colliding lead nuclei heavy
ions as we call them the beginning of
November and it'll operate in this mode
for one month already after just two
weeks of operation with lead ions we've
started to analyze the data we're
already starting to publish papers it's
an extremely exciting time this doesn't
happen often you know and they started a
new machine and we've entered a new era
colliding these heavy nuclei at these
high energies and we expect to have some
discoveries over the next 5-10 years
maybe even only the next year or two